AGNES VAN RHIJN: New York
is a collection of villages.
The old have been in charge
since before the revolution...
until the new people invaded.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
MARIAN BROOK: Well, I'm new.
I've only just arrived.
You are my niece
and you belong to old New York.
OSCAR VAN RHIJN: George Russell
is a power in the land.
Before long, he'll put money
into his pocket
with every train ticket you buy.
I think we should know
the Russell family.
We do not move
in the same circles.
Momma, you are incorrigible.
I take that
as the highest praise.
Well, how do you
find your aunts?
MARIAN: Ada is kind,
but not clever.
And Agnes is clever,
but not kind.
Mrs. Van Rhijn
and her sad sister
were spying on me today.
I don't know why
you bother with them.
BERTHA RUSSELL:
I don't bother with them.
I'm afraid New York can be
quite challenging at first.
We haven't found it so,
have we George?
There is no challenge
you are not equal to, my dear.
AGNES: We have invited Marian
to live with us.
She hasn't a penny.
I cannot live
within Aunt Agnes' confines.
AGNES: You must meet the
right people in the right way.
Money isn't everything, Agnes.
(AGNES LAUGHS)
I don't understand
why they have taken you in.
PEGGY SCOTT: I have a job
and the fresh start that I need.
I want to do something
with my life.
For a New Yorker,
anything is possible.
You are the future,
Mrs. Russell.
And if you are the future,
then they must be the past.
Well, things move faster
nowadays.
I hope you're not
against Miss Scott.
SPEAKER: She'll disrupt things.
Maybe we need
a bit of disruption.
Let the tournament begin.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
Why don't we just go outside
and roll in the gutter?
It will save time.
Do you know of Newport well,
Miss Russell?
The mistress is not a player
in the great game.
That woman is unsuitable
as an acquaintance.
I'll make them pay one day.
SPEAKER 2: How can anyone
be so wretched?
You bastard.
I may be a bastard,
Mr. Thorburn...
but you are a fool.
And of the two,
I think I know which I prefer.